donc à partir de l'horizontale
j'additionne les petits morceaux de
terre un petit peu si vous voulez comme
j'additionne rennais beauceville
ces images datent de 2005 jacqueline
lerat alors 85 ans et elle continue à
travailler la terre comme elle l'a fait
durant toute sa vie avec jean son époux
on n'a jamais si vous voulez basé notre
notre vie sur la sur une recherche de
perfection de 2d pour moi c'est toujours
le sens qui est maire
[Musique]
on
ses oeuvres sont signées jean et
jacqueline lerat des objets des
sculptures en céramique pendant 50 ans
et qu'on crée d'abord à la borne en
contribuant à la réputation du lieu
puis dans leur atelier à bouge dans les
années 70 leur créativité et leur savoir
faire leur valent la reconnaissance de
leurs pairs
[Musique]
parmi leurs sources d'inspiration le
corps humain jacques une sculpte le sien
celui des autres si on pourrait croire
on pourrait imaginer qu'il s'agit de
manoeuvres abstraites en fait jacqueline
lerat n'essaie pas de traduire le corps
dans une oeuvre abstraite elle veut au
contraire en saisir le mouvement dans
l'espace pour cela donc elle déstructure
elle le fait naître en fait c'est le
corps tel qu'il est dans son imaginaire
jean l'aura aussi sculpte des corps les
siens sont boursouflés il y inscrit sa
propre douleur
il souffre d'une malformation de la
colonne vertébrale qui le paralyse peu à
peu
au fur et à mesure que ce que ça s'est
aggravé donc il a essayé il a abandonné
le corps pour saisir des choses qui vais
vous qui voyez quotidiennement la vague
l'eau la fumée qui monte qui s'élève
dans le ciel des moments d'élévation qui
se traduisent en fait cette envie
d'aller dans un ailleurs alors que son
corps empêcher de vivre le présent
il reste aujourd'hui très peu d'oeuvres
des deux artistes décédés
la galerie capezza propose aux visiteurs
et aux collectionneurs des pièces
emblématiques et rares à ne pas rater